[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
賃貸というものをご存知でしょうか今や私
はじめ社長4件の法律を自分で買って自分
の家に住んでるんですけれどもそれまでは
賃貸家賃を払ってお家を大家さんとか管理
人から借りて
済ませていただいてた時期が結構ずーっと
大学生時代からあったんですけれども
賃貸お家を借りる時に家賃というものが
存在するんですよ家賃どんぐらいだったか
な俺が大学1年生の時に住んでたレオ
パレスとかはだいたい家具付きで月6万と
か
静岡ね結構それぐらいなんですよ6番とか
5万とか4万とかしばらく住んでたら3階
建ての賃貸一軒家っぽく見えるあれ賃貸で
あそこがだいたい月15万円ぐらいで僕今
東京にも実はうち借りてますえー
港区の某所のマンションがだいたい
家を管理してる人から借りれるシステム
賃貸本当に値段の幅がもう無限大なんです
よ高級タバコみたいにめちゃくちゃ高い
賃貸もあれば
めっちゃくちゃ安い賃貸もある
[音楽]
めちゃくちゃ安い賃貸
一番安いのいくらなんでしょうねはいと
いうわけで今回私初めて社長日本で
一番安い
賃貸の物件に来ました
高知県後ろ見てください自然が豊か
自然が豊か私今ですね四国の高知県の方に
来ております
[音楽]
虫かゆい結構きつい
結構あの衝撃的な量の虫がいるわけなん
ですが私初めて社長が今いるところもう
日本地図で言うと今このここです高知県
四国の
めっちゃくちゃ左端もうちょっと行ったら
海があるぐらいこれワンチャン大分泳いで
いきますこんな場所にですね日本一安い
賃貸のお家発見しましたでねわかんない
ひょっとしたらもっと安い賃貸世の中に
存在するかもしれないんですよこの日本に
なんですけども
撮影が可能撮影許可が出た賃貸は間違い
なくここが日本で一番安い物件ですなんか
でも安すぎるとその何なんだろう住めない
のかな人が住めない環境だったりなんか
撮影許可が出なくて多分映せないんだと
思う映せないレベルのやつを取り除いて
撮影可能な賃貸では間違いなくここが
一番安い賃貸でございます
探すのに3ヶ月かかりました
3ヶ月かけて探したからもうね間違いない
のよここが一番安い日本で最も安い賃貸
果たして月何円なのでしょうかそしてその
値段相応の中身なのかちょっと早速見て
いきたいと思いますでは行こう
はいというわけで外装どういう感じなのか
ちょっと見ていきたいと思いますひょっと
したらめちゃくちゃ綺麗かもしれないし
台湾かもしれない一軒家かもしれないし何
号室とかなんだろうねちょっと気になるん
ですけどももうすぐそこにあります見てみ
ましょう
[音楽]
でしょうでしょうね
そんな気はしましたここが日本一安い
賃貸のお家です
見えない
どういう建物なのかが見えない
ちなみに僕今日ここ泊まります
隣のトトロだね
[音楽]
結構衝撃的な見た目してますけども見た
感じさやっぱ積めるようにはなってるのか
なちゃんと
郵便受とかあるし
[音楽]
ここ行くんだ
風の通り道だねいやすごいなもうどこが
入り口やねんって感じではあるんですが
[音楽]
あーでも意外と結構大きいぞ
え普通にお家じゃねおいみんなすごいぞ
大きいぞなんかもっとさマンションの1
部屋何丸何号室とか思ってたんですけども
家だねちゃんとここが一番安いんだ結構
衝撃的なデカさですけどただ立地条件とし
てはですねもう全部山で囲まれててパーツ
を目に入るところあの
[音楽]
お店はないお店とかそういうなんか食べ物
屋さんとか何か売ってそうなものは何一つ
見当たりませんちょっと言ったらあったり
するのでしょうかちょっとまだ僕来た
ばっかりでわかんないんですけどじゃあ
早速入ってみたいと思います
鍵ちゃんとありますので
失礼します
日本一安いですから
楽しみですよ
いつか顔
失礼します
これ
普通のお家っぽくね
[音楽]
なんか普通のお家っぽい気がするけど
とりあえずブレーカー上げてみるか
関連しないよね
全部とりあえず
全部あげました
失礼します
え死体とか出てこないよねあついたついた
つきましたはいというわけでお部屋の中が
侵入できました
侵入という言い方悪いけどちゃんと電気も
通ってるし俺何も知らずに来たんですけど
広そうなのよちょっと普通だったら全部
見せてから値段言おうと思ってたんです
けど先に家賃言っときますねなんかそっち
の方が
値段を想像しながら家の中見れると思うの
よこの金額なんだと思って先に発表させて
いただきますこのうち
家賃
月5000円です
NintendoSWITCHのソフト
入れやすいのよもう5000円ででもこの
大きさって言ったら結構なんか良さげな気
がするけどなちょっとすごくない
5000円でこれってもっとなんか1Kと
かのイメージだったんですけどもここだけ
でだって1系以上ありそうな気がします
けどこれで5000円なんですよなんと
はいというわけで外もうちょっと見てみ
ましょうかまだねお家の全容が見えてない
のよ
草だらけで結構でも大きそうな気がするん
ですよね
家が全部草で覆われてて
びっくり
すごいな
ぁ
なんかここ建物もう一個ここも
行けんのかこれ
これ行けんのかな
[音楽]
ここで行き止まりぽいですけどもなんか何
個か建物があるっぽいですね
5000円でこれは破格よ
買えます
ね
これすごいよほらここ
入れなくなってんじゃないかな多分です
けど物とか入れる倉庫みたいな感じなんだ
と思いますもう鶴がすごくて扉開かなそう
だなこれ
ジブリか
ぐるっと回ってきたんですけども外観は
こんな感じだと思いますはいうーん
なんかジブリっぽくて素敵な道ですけど
僕あんまり好きじゃないですすごいなぁ
結構でもボロボロではありますねまあ値段
相応な気はします
なんか戻ろう
はいというわけでちょっと色々見ていき
ましょうか
[音楽]
暗い
電気普通に使うんかなこれ
あついたついたあちゃんと作る
ごめんなさい閲覧注意です
雲移りますそのバカでかいの雲をさっきも
言ったんですよね実はやばいな
これが
値段の理由か次はこの部屋行ってみようと
思います
なんか作りかけてるなんか作りたかったの
かな失礼します
これで電気つくよね
はい
[音楽]
うわぁこの時差でつく感じめっちゃ実家
っぽい
結構
綺麗な感じではありますねおすげえ
奥にもまだ部屋がある何ここ
[音楽]
なんかここ
綺麗そうな感じがライトライト
[音楽]
めっちゃいいじゃん
えこれ本当に
そんな値段で前本当にこれそんな値段なの
か
なんか
嘘でしょ
すごくないすごくないこの値段でこの広さ
よちゃんと手入れしたらさ普通に
素敵なお家になれそうだけど本当に
めっちゃいいけどな広いし
ちょっとまだまだお部屋あるので見ていき
ましょう次はここです
[音楽]
失礼しますちょっとなるべく電気つけ
まくってみるねはい
[音楽]
おーなるほどなるほど寝室ぽいですねいや
でもよくできてる気がするけどななんか
入ってるのかな
[音楽]
ここはあ押し入れ的なねなんか前住んでた
人のものがたくさんあるからあんまり
[音楽]
払拭したくないですけどもここ寝室ですね
いやでもめちゃくちゃ広いぞえ
っでかくねなんであんな値段になっちゃっ
てるんだろう
家自体がやっぱ外装とかボロボロだからと
かお手入れされてないからとかですかね
それにしても
めっちゃくちゃいいですけどねちょっと
どんどん見ていきましょう個人的にこの
部屋がすごいなんか
可愛くて素敵いや信じがたいですけどね
広い
めちゃくちゃ広いですけども2階建てでは
なさそうなので多分上とかないんだろうな
そんな感じはします
ただまだまだ部屋があります
[音楽]
ここが台所
キッチンですかね
あの本当に言葉を選ばず言うと
汚いちょっとやっぱボロボロのところが
あるなぁこれを全部新しくしようとか
なんかリフォームしようとするとめっちゃ
大変そう
マキマさんの目みたいなツボがあるの
[音楽]
ここにもちょっと広めのお部屋がありまし
た広い
めちゃくちゃ物の収納とかできるしいやー
広いまず第一印象が
値段と見合わずめちゃくちゃ広いという
印象があります
[音楽]
でまだ多くあるんでしょうすごいなおい
トイレっぽいですねちょっと開けてみます
失礼します
[音楽]
お風呂場だお風呂場ですねなるほど
入りたくないですでも聞いたところお風呂
も使えるって聞きましたということはここ
が
トイレかなあートイレだちっちゃ
昔ならではの大きさちっちゃいはい一通り
見たんですけどもこういう感じの間取りに
はなって
ますいやマジで無理
ガチで無理です
はいというわけでこんな感じのお部屋に
なっています
白いわ皆さんこれ
5000円ですよ
やばいやもちろんなんか手入れされてない
部分とか結構古い建物っぽいので
汚れていたりとかちょっとなんかボロボロ
だったりする場所あるんですけども
ちゃんとお金かけたりリフォームとか
入れればマジでいい家になる気はします
[音楽]
やらんけど僕はやらないですよ僕はやら
ないですけどももし仮にここに住みたい
その金額で攻めていく人がいたら
めっちゃなんか有効活用できそうな広さ
家族でも住める大きさだよ家族で住んで
その値段やばくないですかちょっと
びっくりしてます普通にこれが最低金額な
んだっていう1キーとかじゃないんだね
びっくりです今もう日が暮れてきて
ちょっとお腹すいたのでここに止まると
言いつつも飯は外で食っています
はいというわけで帰ってきました
焼肉食べました
[音楽]
[拍手]
いやコーチねご飯
美味しい
めちゃくちゃ
美味しくですね焼肉屋さんあの他のお客
さん一人もいなかったんですけども
美味しく食べさせていただきましたご
ちそうさまでしたちょっとあの
値段的に1Kとか一人しか入れないだろう
なぐらいの大きさをイメージしてたんです
けどもこんなに大きな思わなかったので
ちょっと
寂しかったので
スペシャルゲストお呼びしましたどうぞ
[音楽]
お前かいどうもこんにちはイケメンです
ありがとうございますいやここその事故
物件とかじゃなくてはい普通の賃貸なので
なるほどこんだけ広いんだったらなんか
一人でいるんじゃなくて後輩も一緒にい
させようと思って今日はイケメンサーベも
泊まっていきますよろしくお願いしますお
願いしますちょっと住んでみるとどういう
感じかが知りたいので値段による満足度と
かすごい気になるのでちょっと今日は
泊まってみたいと思います
[音楽]
はい皆さんとんでもないことに気づきまし
たこの家エアコンあるわ
今気づいたエアコンあるわなんか他の部屋
とか回った時エアコンが見つからなかった
んですよ
この寝室上見てくださいほら
エアコンがないんですよこっちの部屋も
ないよねうん
はいエアコン和室もないですこの部屋も
もちろんないです
ということはこの流れ多分
キッチンも
ないですこれは困った今ね8月のもうは
もう処理真っ只中なんですよ普通に
めちゃくちゃ暑いこれ泊まれるのか
暑いんですよ普通に何もしなくても汗かく
から今タンクトップ来ててうわーそういう
ことがこれは住めねえやと思ったところに
まさかの
はいはい皆さんこれマジで大事ここで
エアコンがつかないかで僕の人生
命関わってきます
リモコンはどこだ
これがリモコンなのか電池入ってる
壊れてるね
終わったリモコン壊れてる終わった
だったら直接つけれないから
リモコンがダメだったら直接つけるしか
ない生き物とか出てこないよねほんとそう
いうのだけやめてね
家具が結構ボロボロで怖いんですけども
エアコンつけるならやばいうまい運転
[音楽]
あーダメだ
これやばいわ使うわこれ逆にもう中の電池
入れてついたら勝ち目あるかこれね
エアコンつけないと死にます
電池電使ってくる
はい帰ってきました
最寄りのコンビニまで車で30分ぐらい
ですね俺が見た感じだと多分30分
圏内には物を買えたりとか食べ物変えたり
する場所分かんないあるのかなあるかも
しれないけどコンビニはね一番近くで30
分ぐらいでしたサラダ問題はこの新しい
電池に付け替えることによりエアコンが
つくかどうかそれによってこの家での生存
率は大きく変わってきます
普通にね暑い日とかもう
えっ来ました
ついた
から来てる
冷房
来る
いつから使われてないんだろう
排気ガスできたらどうしようちょっと古
すぎてなんかやばいの飛んできたりするか
が心配ですけどもまいっかもう暑すぎて
普通に汗止まんないんで
涼しい分には助かりますね
涼しいの出てるかな
それで全然話変わってくるよ
[音楽]
皆さん来ました
勝利です
この家は神これでかなり快適に過ごせるん
じゃないかなはいというわけでもう結構夜
遅いのでそろそろ寝ようかなって感じなん
ですけれども1個気になった点があったの
よちょっとこっち見てみましょう
[音楽]
この寝室寝室
多分誰が寝てたんだろうお部屋のですね
ここ
[音楽]
わかるおーなんかあるこの扉めっちゃ
怪しくねなんかすごい形と言いますか神棚
の場所というかさこんな高い場所に普通
棚つけないでしょっていうのでちょっと
怪しい
どうしようゴキブリ出てきたら出そうはい
開けてみたいと思いますお願いします
[音楽]
人いる可能性あります
ちょっとなんかガタンと言ったけど何も
ないよね大丈夫です
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばい
すごい優しさダメだこれなんか多分中に
ひき肉入ってるこれひき肉です
こういう感じでしょパチンになって
そんな感じです
はいというわけでエアコンが効いてはない
なんかちょっとだけ暑さが軽くなったか
なっていう感じがしますなんか冷たい風は
吹いてこないような感じがしますちょっと
だけ涼しいんですけどねなんとか寝れそう
な環境ではあるのでもう早速寝たいと思い
ますじゃあ寝る準備
大丈夫かなんか蜘蛛とか顔登ってきたら俺
マジで普通に俺の一番近くにいる人死ぬ
ことになるけどいいそれ俺です
そのままね
それ正解説ある多分床がちょっと
片付いてないのってこうやって寝るのが
いい気がするなぁ
欲しい
エアコン大丈夫かすごい
ハウスキーなんだねきっと
いやーもうパッと見心霊動画だけどね
ここは
被爆付きでもないです
管理者もいますただ
[音楽]
値段がやばい
やばい
本当だ
時間が
あっちい死んじゃう死んじゃう
つける
[音楽]
まずいまず
助けて
本気出していい
[音楽]
エアコンがつかなくなりました
致命的や
暑いでこれ
びっくりするなぜなんでだろう
[音楽]
終わった
暑いよ
いっす
かもしれないです
[音楽]
まだ寝なきゃ明るくなるまでここにおるん
やおやすみなさい
外でイケメン
[音楽]
おはようございます
朝だなはいというけどちょっとちゃんと
寝れはしなかったんですけど一応一晩日本
一安い賃貸に泊まってみました
そんなになんかすぎて本当
途中止まっちゃったんですけどもエアコン
の効いた部屋からも出れなくて暑くてただ
これちゃんとしたら本当になんか攻めそう
な気がしましたそして1Kの1部屋とか
じゃなくて部屋もたくさんあるっていうね
なんか全然これが一番安いのかと思うよう
な構造はすごいしっかりしたおむつだなと
思いましたなんかこういう知らないお部屋
とかお家に住むの結構楽しいのでまた
面白い物件あったら皆さん是非教えて
ください
泊まりたいと思います帰りますおやすみ
[音楽]